[Music]
in copenhagen people are running for
their lives
shoppers desperately trying to escape
and this is why
inside a mall a man can be seen pacing
with a gun
shots had been fired
yet here he seems calm as he swings the
weapon over his shoulder
something grabs his attention
and he runs off
armed police are on the scene
trying to get people to safety
[Music]
i saw people running away from tomorrow
we thought that it was some fans that
were seeing harry styles we were
supposed to
have a concert in
half an hour so
but
after some time the cops came ambulance
and the
firemen came i went outside to uh
reception
and and i asked what was happening and
some said if there was a shooting
as police surround the building
inside they're tracking the gunman
people are told to hide
officers later confirmed a 22 year old
danish man had been arrested
they said terrorism couldn't be ruled
out
what we're looking at now is whether
we're dealing with just the suspect who
we apprehended alone
or if this is something that was done
with others
pop star harry styles cancelled a
concert he was playing nearby and in a
message online said he was praying for
all involved
this city now remains on high alert
several people have died
several others have been injured
victims in a shooting where the motive
remains unclear
siobhan robbins sky news